a 50,000 Bolivar note that was Venezuela
central banks most recent attempt to
curb the galloping devaluation of money
and shortage of cash it has helped
little that amid international sanctions
against the Socialists Maduro government
the value of the bolivar continued to
plummet leaving people desperate for
hard currency this Caracas restaurant
sells pastries called empanadas like
other businesses it accepts electronic
payments but there's still many
customers who prefer paying in cash in
US dollars every day people ask whether
we take cash but we obviously don't
accept large bills dollars are accepted
just about everywhere in Caracas even at
this market this trader doesn't want to
be filmed at first it looks like the
eggs are being paid for with the
boulevard the national currency but it
turns out to be US dollars there's more
to this trend and just the collapse of
Venezuela's currencies says economists
run of Bozza
look a unicycle ascended all arrays at
the moment there are large amounts of
dollars bolivars pesos and other
currencies in circulation we've been
through hyperinflation at the same time
the central bank has allowed the cash to
dollars in circulation to lose their
value very quickly without adjusting the
banknotes accordingly in Kota monetary
[Music]
it's hard to say how dollars enter
Venezuela since the central bank no
longer provides information on foreign
exchange receipts but the greenback is
clearly being circulated here when it
comes to dollars from private sources we
don't know how much there is or why
there is a law that prevents currency
trading but it's getting less
transparent because people have to spend
their money secretly even if the money
comes from legitimate sources of course
there's also money from illegitimate
sources like drugs it's very difficult
to determine
some Venezuelans send remittances home
in u.s. dollars stimulating the import
market there are no shortages in this
Caracas supermarket but the imports here
are two or three times more expensive
than those in Europe or in the u.s. some
stores only sell imports bodega nays are
luxury import shops can be found almost
everywhere
which a lot of people don't earn dollars
so it's hard to pay in dollars so much
happens under the table including the
use of the dollar there's a lot that's
not legal I'm still paid in bolivars and
now everything I want to buy is sold in
dollars already economists have no
illusions about the situation as long as
there's no realistic foreign exchange
policy informal supply and demand will
determine how people pay for goods